welcome to the Friday show all right Pat
I've got a confession to make
we have a decoy story here in segment a
of the show Pat has been asking me all
day do I think the story we're launching
with today is going to be long enough to
fill the time we have and I've been
telling Pat yeah I swallow enough it's
long enough and it is a total decoy
story because I actually have a very
special celebration for Pat's birthday
which is upcoming and I'm having the
interns not in the room we have our
intern Brian coming in we are going to
be having a vegan dessert sampling Wow
and I've had to play this casually
because clearly the story I had it's a
legitimate story I won't even tell
people what it is but it was not enough
time and Pat noticed it Pat noticed it
doesn't don't feel like we've got enough
material through eight minutes on this
we can't do eight minutes on it and
you're right we can't because it was a
cover because it is Pat's birthday over
the weekend this being the Friday show
is the last show so Brian by all means
please uncover the vegan desserts and
let's place them in front of Pat here
these are 100% vegan desserts which
we're going to sample well and I will
describe what's on here we can hold them
up should I grab a couple and then you
can take the rest yeah well these are
all I'm going to sample them but no all
the leftovers are all for you here and
we'll figure out how to get a couple
over me so what we have here are three
desserts that are everything free not
only are they vegan they're soy free
they're gluten free I don't even know
how I think it's air essentially yes it
is it's free of everything and we've got
a coconut covered marshmallows and some
kind of chocolate cake and all sorts of
different things this is awesome you had
no idea right well no because my
birthday falls on a Saturday the dryers
which is perfectly fair yeah yeah this
is an awesome surprise all right so
let's see if we can if you I don't know
if you want to bring over I'll grab a
couple things off the tray here Brian
and these are all sustainably sourced
that you conflict-free marshmallows and
everything all right I'll grab the story
with a salsa flag you could give the
story with a complete ball too laughs
yeah I've prepared great points for it
absolutely yeah it's so it was a waste
all right I think this is good I'll keep
these over
here so we these are what should we
sample first here maybe like this
marshmallow yeah the marshmallow seems
good I'm a fan of marshmallows okay and
by the way feel free to dig in Brian
yeah very coconutty sugary it's
absolutely vegan that I can tell you for
sure I like how you're taking bites and
I just put the whole thing in my mouth
well I'm thinking about it more as a UH
as a process yeah okay all right this
one's okay yeah my favorite okay let's
go next to what I would describe as it's
a peanut butter cup like thing how would
you describe this a peanut butter cup
but I don't it's not actually a peanut
butter cup and again it is completely
vegan and it has at its base is nougat
vegan I think so what is nougat I don't
even know what we know I don't think
anyone knows what mecha and if the paper
vegan to the paper is edible it's
completely vegan and gluten-free as well
I remember on you nougat growing up with
the thing where if you thought you were
getting a legit chocolate bar and then
it turned out to be a nougat one instead
of having an actual cookie crunch that
was bad like you guys have short end of
the stick I actually don't know if this
is nougat I think it might be like
cashew based or something like that
okay let's try now of any peanut butter
cup like thing that's pretty good that's
good this is more like a fudge type
thing this is fake news and I'm sensing
also mint are you are you tasting mint
yeah it's an aftertaste Wow I don't know
how to describe this but it's definitely
chocolate that I know I think one of our
viewers mentioned he was going to send
in some vegan butter too yeah we didn't
get it okay
trust me okay I like I mean listen I
don't know anything about vegan desserts
um but this seems to be one what about
brute brute down from the right we like
Bruno I know about Alex
and such things all right I like this
yeah and then now the third one that we
have and I'm actually not going to try
this one because we only have two of
them and I want to make sure you get
both of them so nice this is a an actual
proper chocolate how would you describe
this thing I don't know you're the one
that's good with words this is a it's
sort of laughs it's almost like a
pudding like no it's not putting
hardened pudding it's hard and put it I
mean it's a softer it's a softer cake
I'm always terrible about it all right
so then I feel like it's more it's like
a mousse like substance yeah no I'm
gonna be messy I'm glad this is the last
thing that we're recording today yeah
do I do it dig right in that's going in
and he has sampled it oh I'm gonna go to
my lip described it the flavors it was
like it's like mousse okay from the base
of it but there's a hardened chocolate
at the top would you describe it as a
cookie crunch this is easily my favorite
really because I'm a big chocolate guy
okay I have a lot of dark chocolates and
everything else this is this is
fantastic
very good yeah very good this may be the
best present I get for the rest of my
life well let's not go too far so it is
Pat's birthday and Pat you'll be pleased
to know you've also got a gift card
coming Pat recently moved and he may
have items that he needs to purchase so
you've got a gift card which will be
delivered to you by email on the actual
day of your birthday I wanted to save
something for the actual birthday I wish
I had more to say yeah I'm so flattered
over here but I think the audience will
be pleased to know that I did not opt to
try to force non-vegan desserts on to
Pat I don't know that he would have been
susceptible to that type of peer
pressure anyway yeah but we don't even
have to think about that because these
are actual vegan desserts other than the
last one which is made with cream but
they called it vegan like so I think
we're fine and I'm going to be 23 -
which means I'll be very very wise at
that age and I think even approaching a
quarter life crisis you could say yeah I
thought the crisis happened last week oh
yeah well that was bad we won't
all right so happy birthday to Pat I
predict the number of happy birthdays
from the audience I predict the number
of invitations to various types of
romantic evenings from the audience so
which which has which can happen really
but it doesn't have no verification
whatsoever it doesn't really have to be
your birthday but I think the audience
will see it as an opportunity and on
that note we still have an entire other
show here today any special plans for
your birthday Pat I think there's gonna
be fireworks on my birthday because I
live on well
my parents live on this Lake okay yeah
didn't pay too much more yeah they do a
fake 4th thing like two weeks after the
fourth of July and the fireworks of the
water just so happens to coincide with
my birthday this year so that's alright
pretty awesome well don't hurt yourself
we have often stories about amateur
fireworks accidents here in
Massachusetts because you can go up and
cross over into New Hampshire and buy
fireworks which is legal there but once
you cross them to Massachusetts of
course that is illegal and I assume
since your family is law enforcement
involved there would be no illegal
activity at all
and I like my thumbs I want to set off
any firecrackers I like them intact yeah
alright well listen we will then
reconvene on Monday here with a an older
and wiser Pat hopefully with all
appendages still attached yes and on
that note we will take a break and jump
into the rest of the show